tulsi gabbard and mitt romney are having
a bit of a tiff as you might expect
tulsi is right and mitt is wrong what is
the tiff about it's about something that
we've talked a lot about on this show in
the last couple of weeks
the bio labs in ukraine that were funded
and in part built by the united states
that the official story coming out of
the united states deep state was these
labs don't exist okay they do exist but
we're not involved okay they exist and
we fund them and we built some of them
but it's just for ordinary scientific
research okay it's actually run by the
military but the pathogens that are
being studied or aren't really dangerous
uh oh okay we're they're actually
extremely dangerous and we're terrified
they're falling into russian hands so
that's quite the evolution of the story
we called it out and the minute that you
mention any of this the minute that you
contradict the official narrative coming
out of the american deep state you're
called a putin stooge or a
xi jinping stooge or anti-american or a
traitor or whatever you're just you're
just pointing out the facts on the
ground that are that even the state
department is now admitting is true so
tulsi gabbard made a huge mistake of
talking about something that we know
exists
here are the undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the us government
these bio labs are conducting research
on dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities
even in the best of circumstances could
easily be compromised and release these
deadly pathogens
now like covid
these pathogens know no borders
if they are inadvertently or purposely
breached or compromised they will
quickly spread
all throughout europe the united states
and the rest of the world causing
untold suffering and death
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens that they
hold need to be destroyed
did you hear anything wrong with what
she said
i didn't the facts that she observed are
undeniable at this point we've we've
talked about it on the show we've
brought the documents from the state
department from the pentagon the labs
exist the labs are studying dangerous
pathogens both the state department and
the pentagon now admit that that's the
case do you disagree with your
conclusion that we've got to secure the
labs that if these things break out
after two years of a pandemic involving
a virus that very likely came from a lab
that coincidentally we were also funding
the wuhan institute of virology after
dealing with that experience for two
years even if we hadn't dealt with it
for two years even if that hadn't
happened just knowing you've got
dangerous pathogens that can can
run all the way around the world
obviously we need to shut down these
labs we need to secure them they're in a
war zone with russian tanks rolling in
could you disagree with anything that
she just said
mitt romney did
mitt romney tweeted out quote tulsi
gabbard is parroting false russian
propaganda her treasonous lies
may well cost lives
now
mitt romney didn't have any follow-up
tweets because he's completely full of
it he's saying it's false russian
propaganda to say that the us was
funding bio labs in ukraine
there's nothing false about it it is
true that the russians used the true
existence of those biolabs as propaganda
the chinese used it as propaganda too
but the very best propaganda has a basis
in fact and the fact is the u.s military
was funding these biola and is still
funding these bio labs and has been
since 2005.
so that's just a fact
it's not it's not false propaganda it's
a true fact and mitt romney is calling
this woman a traitor an american service
member tulsi gabbard and a former member
of congress calling her a traitor and a
murderer for stating the truth
mitt freaking romney somehow on the
wrong side of almost every political
issue he is involved in
these days
and many in the past too i i really
don't want to hear it from the squishes
anymore that mitt romney is some kind of
good guy he's a good guy you know he
might be a little liberal on some issues
but he look he's a good guy he's an
honorable man he's a liar he's an
absolute liar he has no integrity
whatsoever when he ran for senate
against ted kennedy in boston that was
the first time he ran for senate in
massachusetts then he moved to new
hampshire to run for president then he
moved to utah because he lost both of
those races so he moved to utah so he
could finally become a senator but when
he was running for senate in in
massachusetts he was going up against
teddy kennedy he was asked he was he
said he was very very pro-choice right
forget about those little babies those
little babies don't matter he was trying
to enter the united states senate and
then he was even asked about the legacy
of ronald reagan this is the easiest
lay-up this is such a gimme for
conservatives if conservatives want to
get elected in the mainstream way all
you have to do is say i like ronald
reagan i'm going to be the next ronald
reagan and he couldn't even do that
during during his 1994 senate race he
said i i wasn't a republican during the
time of reagan i i was an independent
during the time of reagan i don't want
to be anything like reagan and then what
he runs for president he says i'm the
i'm the reincarnation of ronald reagan
he's just a putts he's just an absolute
rudderless
completely integrity lacking putts okay
and he's going after this woman tulsi
gabbard for telling the truth it's
disgusting kind of stuff and it makes
you wonder
what degree of freedom of speech do we
have in this country anymore what degree
forget freedom of the press even just
freedom basic freedom of speech for a
service member and former member of
commerce congress to
come out and say these bio labs exist
this is a real threat it was kind of
covered up by the government now they're
admitting it's true and it really
changes the calculation in this war in
ukraine and we've got to be careful
about it and the minute you make that
obvious modest true point
you get this guy mitt romney to come
after you and say you're a traitor and
you're a liar and you're a putin stooge
disgusting absolutely disgusting
mitt romney is no different than those
cackling hens on the view as far as i'm
concerned i'm glad you like that clip
now i need you to ring the bell please
you'll get the notifications you'll
subscribe and then also head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l space k-n-w-l-e-s space
w
s-h-o-w-sub
right now you will get all of our latest
episodes we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]